ganz Deutschland ist im Griff der
klimakleber so erscheint es und das
Internet ist voll von Videos wie diesem
ich glaube einfach noch nie so nah
alles passiert trotzdem nichts
was machen wir so Angst
bei der Regierung hat keinen Plan
darfst nicht im knüpfen
Frau Gaschke wecken diese Interview
diese Videos Interviews sind ja nicht
Mitgefühl in ihn also ein bisschen
Mitgefühl und ein bisschen die Frage ist
das nicht Satire und ein bisschen das
Gefühl also brauchen die mal ein paar um
die Ohren also es ist tatsächlich sehr
gegen körperliche Zustimmung
nein es ist natürlich es ist ja das gute
Recht junger Leute ideologisch zu sein
und fanatisch zu sein und sich in Ideen
rein zu steigern und so weiter das tun
sie wahrscheinlich immer irgendwie das
macht wirklich das ist keine Satire war
ein Mädchen Pauline filmt und ihre Angst
ja vor dem klimawand Angst das haben wir
in Corona gelernt ist auch ein ideales
Erpressungsmittel also mit seiner
eigenen Angst kann man andere Leute toll
unter Druck setzen weil man darf nicht
dagegen sagen das wäre fies schon was
ich jetzt sage ist unheimlich fies weil
ich das nicht ernst nehme ich ich stehe
also ich kann das nicht beurteilen wie
viel Angst sie tatsächlich persönlich
hat ich finde nur nicht dass sie und
andere das Recht haben alle anderen ihre
Angst zu terrorisieren sondern wir sind
hier immer noch ein demokratischer Staat
und wenn man der Meinung ist es muss
viel schneller viel mehr passieren dann
muss man dafür werben dann muss man
dafür Leute auf seine Seite ziehen die
mitmachen wollen da muss man dafür in
Parteien gehen oder selber Parteien
Gründen und um Mehrheiten werben denn
ich meine diese Klimabewegung muss ich
doch auch selbst ernst nehmen also die
die die die die wissen doch dass es wenn
es so ist wie sie sagen und es so
schnell gehen muss und so doll dass sie
viele Leute zum Mitmachen bewegen müssen
im Moment stoßen sie alle Leute ab und
und Leute wir alle merken in uns dass
wir so irgendwie zu viel drakonischeren
Strafen neigen und und und also
irgendwie das Gefühl haben so kann das
Kinder so kann das wirklich weitergehen
im Dialog wenn sie jetzt im Dialog mit
Pauline werden aus dem Video was würden
Sie Ihr denn entgegnen
naja ehrlich gesagt mir fällt das auch
ein bisschen schwer also das ernst zu
nehmen also ich finde das ist
pathologisch also das ist wirklich
pathologisch natürlich ist der
Klimawandel etwas was man wo man etwas
dagegen tun muss aber so zu tun als
würde jetzt irgendwie also erstmal kann
Deutschland das nicht alleine das heißt
nicht soll kein Alibi sein nicht zu
machen aber so zu tun als würden wir
also zum Beispiel wenn wir unsere ganze
Industrie killen klar sind wir dann
vorbildlich in unseren Klimazielen die
Industrie produziert nur woanders und
meistens dreckiger also
suchen ich will da noch ganz viel von
ihnen heute hören geben wir aber einmal
zu Herrn oder der seine These auch zu
dem Thema heute mitgebracht hat und
vielleicht auch eine Lösung hat wie man
mit Pauline und den anderen umgeht ja
ich würde Paulinen öffentlichen
Therapeuten empfehlen vorausgesetzt es
ist wirklich authentisch und nicht aus
ein Clip aus der heute show was da
wunderbar reinpassen würde aber es tut
mir leid die machen solche Witze aber
nicht
also es ist immer peinlich wenn gerne
oder alte Frauen über junge Menschen
lästern und ich habe ja auch einen
ordentlichen
alte Männer am Anfang ich habe auch ein
ordentlichen demonstrationshintergrund
aber uns haben damals die
Demonstrationen noch Spaß gemacht das
sind alles kranke Menschen deswegen
haben sie vollkommen Recht entschuldigen
Sie dass ich einen zustimme das ist
pathologische Phänomen sind das sind
paranoika und Hysteriker in einer
paranoiden und hysterischen Gesellschaft
und deswegen fliegen diesen Leuten auch
viele Herzen zu und einer Argument wenn
sie so machen merke ich soll aufhören
aber jetzt mache ich weiter
ja ich höre immer wieder ich höre immer
wieder in Debatten ja das mag ja falsch
sein aber es ist für einen guten Zweck
der seinen absolut totalitäres Argument
dass man etwas macht das nicht geht weil
der Zweck so gut ist damit sind bis
jetzt alle Diktaturen zum Zuge gekommen
alle Diktaturen
bieten nur das Gute werden und das ist
hier die große Lüge ich meine das sind
junge Menschen die furchtbar leiden weil
glaube ich seit Wörter wollen junge
Menschen auch leiden aber sie haben
keinen richtigen Anlass mehr dazu sie
sind wohl behütet aufgewachsen sie sind
wahrscheinlich auch gut erzogen haben
ordentliche akademische Abschlüsse oder
was auch immer und es geht sogar so weit
dass ich von einer jungen Frau gelesen
habe in Regensburg oder Würzburg also
irgendwo aus der bayerischen Provinz der
hat gesagt sie hat sich sterilisieren
lassen und keine Kinder zu bekommen weil
in dieser Welt kann man keine Kinder
reinsetzen abgesehen davon
noch andere Mittel gibt und keine Kinder
zu junge Sozialisten haben das früher
gemacht um Feministen zu sein ja genau
genau aber das wissen Sie das haut alles
nicht hin die gehören alle auf die Couch
aber die Aktivisten sagen eigentlich
weil Kinder die größte Klima Sünde sind
ja das kann schon so sein dass nächste
Mal in der paar Wochen haben sie gesagt
Haustiere sind die größte Klima Sünde
ich habe schon einen Hund in Sicherheit
gebracht wirklich bevor sie ihn zu einer
Fraktion zum der Grünen einladen nein
schauen Sie wer erleben eigentlich jetzt
eine Katastrophe der Staat hat jetzt
Manifest versagt es sind
Straftatbestände denen wir es zu tun
haben da ist natürlich Nötigung Eingriff
in den Straßenverkehr und ich finde
übrigens auch Geiselnahme
Freiheitsberaubung wenn tausende von
Leuten in den Autos sitzen egal wo die
hin wollten das heißt immer die Mutter
mit Kind zum Arzt egal ich unterwegs zum
Kaffee genauso wichtig denn tausende von
Leuten im Auto sitzen ist das
Geiselnahme und dann heute ist das erste
Urteil mit der nicht bewerten auf Strafe
verlassen worden in Berlin vier Monate
nein viel zu wenig so aber wir wollen
Sie denn Herr Bruder
nein schauen Sie ich wollte nur eins
sagen und dann können Sie wieder
entspannen
der Staat ist ein enteierter Bulle und
der lässt sich das alles bieten und ich
sehe wie die armen Polizisten nicht nur
diese Leute wegtragen müssen sondern die
liebevoll sie die Hände loslösen müssen
mit Olivenöl und anderen wertvollen
Rohstoff wo es sieht jetzt nicht immer
so liebevoll aus also dass der der also
die Polizisten streicheln nicht noch die
Aktivierung
das finde ich aber wir haben es eine
Stadt zusammen zu tun und derweil
derweil lachen alle und freuen sich und
dieser Kids geben ihre Pressekonferenzen
in Kirchen wenn es ginge müsste man
sozusagen im Prinzip die Bühne anziehen
das heißt keine Presse mehr vor Ort
keine Kameras keine Polizisten das geht
nur nicht das wird nicht aber dann wäre
das ganz schnell erledigt weil es keiner
mitkriegt ja es kann nicht ich glaube
das wirklich schlimmer an diesen
Aktionen ist ja dass sie genau das
gegenteilige das den gegenteiligen
Effekt haben den sie sich offenbar
versprechen die Leute werden die kriegen
eine blasse Wut also ich meine ich
verstehe das ich muss zur Arbeit oder
ich muss irgendwohin wo ich pünktlich
sein muss und dann oder ich persönlich
muss zum Beispiel zum Flughafen manchmal
und muss den Flug kriegen so und wenn
man dann äh fliegen noch um Gottes
Willen ja das Saarland ist schon ein
Stückchen weg da kommt man zumindest mit
dieser Bahn die dann ewig verspätet hat
nicht hin also wie gesagt irgendwo muss
man hin man ist in seinem Auto unterwegs
und plötzlich kompletter Stau Klima
Kleber so was ist der Effekt ja die
Leute haben eine stinke Wut auf diese
auf die junge Leute und damit natürlich
auch auf das Ganze klimapproblem also
wenn man es wirklich schaffen will dass
der Begriff Klimaschutz oder Klimawandel
nur noch zu einem anti-begriff wird wo
die Leute fragen Platz dann muss man es
genauso machen und ich finde auch ist
unredlich ich meine was hat der normale
Autofahrer mit dem Klimawandel zu tun
ich meine die können sich das Auto ja
aber selbst ja vielleicht auch nicht
richtig ausgebaut ist oder weil er eben
ja natürlich seine Mobilität haben will
also ich finde ich meine die können sich
vor Habicht Ministerium ankleben den
ganzen Tag Erfolg habe ich nichts
dagegen sie können denjenigen die sie
verantwortlich machen da können sie ihre
Aktion machen alles gut aber dass sie
ganz normale Bürger die wirklich
überhaupt keine Verantwortung dafür
tragen die aber die Leidtragenden sind
in dieser Weise schädigen und wütend
machen und ich meine auch ein
Arbeitgeber sagt ja nicht wenn man dann
viel zu spät kommt ja da war der Klima
da waren die Klima Kleber ne dann sagt
der Arbeitgeber trotzdem dahin so anders
fahren müssen also man kriegt ja Ärger
man hat immer Schwierigkeiten dadurch
und die Leute die das erleben müssen ja
das soll nicht so dass die dann so toll
jetzt müssen wir noch mehr für die für
die Bekämpfung des klimawandes sagen ich
will von diesem Thema nichts mehr hören
ich bin müde
oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung das
kann nicht wahr sein jetzt melden unsere
Reporter kümmern sich um Ihren Fall
kämpft für Sie